the fragrance. I don't even really have questions. I just got comments here.
What would make me want to buy this rather than the product I currently have from Sephora that
I might be buying? Because it's new. Nobody has a product like this. And time is money. People
are busy. I know myself. I'm a busy mom. Sometimes I'm going from soccer practice to home to baseball
practice. And in between, I'm like, I need a spray tan. Oh, crap. I don't have time to shave,
shower exfoliate i want to do it in the salon sink here we go i've got a product i can do it all
don't tell the boss i do that sometimes um first off the sales fact sheet was an awesome touch
helps us understand the story because obviously at first impression it could just seem like a
body wash so obviously you guys did a really good job at conveying that with us so same thing we
got a lot of good comments um no i want i want to go back to this i think at 49 love the concept
of a multifunctional but do you guys see this being something that you could like pair together
with like a promo item and a show if so what item would you pair together with it to help cushion
that price yeah i think that we could pair it with our versus spot i think we could pair it with other
sunless products that we have on the shelf and even expand it to other aftercare products right
like there's a whole um wide range of products that you could pair this with and i don't think
there's just one specific one that you know we could find but i think there's a great opportunity
you can do for it what would you bundle this with specifically is there another product that
you currently carry that you could see bundled together which one moisturizer probably one that
would be similar fragrance that would be more unisex for both men and women would be the aloe
and ocean water great because that was a little bit more yes like clean yes love it good job girls
there you go yes absolutely love the fragrance by the way it's awesome
awesome wow wow wow wow I mean this is just absolutely amazing just with I mean all of the
facts that you've given us the sample to be able to smell it I mean and I absolutely love the fact
that you were really pushing like this is a sunless tan primer it's ph balancing it has
shave minimizers in it and now the one thing and I know you had said it but can you remind me quick
what age range did you have for this product so we did 16 and up and the reason being is obviously
young adolescent now with the pressure of social media everyone wants to look good feel good
the reason that we didn't go younger is because 16 and up is your demographic that they are
employed you know most of these people's parents they don't want to pay for their kids added extra
stuff outside of sephora right so it's also a reasonable price for them to justify it at their
age right so i think it helps to broaden our demographic and although they cannot uv tan we
can encourage the younger ones in for like you know sunless tanning and it's it kind of correlates
with our our launch time we're thinking may to june the reason being you're coming into the time
of year people want to feel good look good everyone's going out like yeah and then one last
question quick is this a daily use product i would say yes and no i think it would depend like if
If you're using it strictly for Versa, I think you would probably want to stay a little bit away from it,
or spray tans in general, just because there could be the possibility that it could strip it a little bit faster.
But I think with the ingredients we have, that it is more of like the moisturization, cooling, and calming on the skin.
So, yeah.
Great answer.
Hey, ladies, I think you guys absolutely 100% nailed the pitch.
Just well-practiced, well-rehearsed, all the supportive materials with it, certainly in the sample.
I don't have a lot to add other than this fragrance. If my wife had this, I don't know
Let's just leave it. I wish you really did
I have, I have to have one
So you know, let's not just leave it alone
Anyways, more than
I was so scared where you were going with that
Absolutely love the pitch. You guys, I literally felt like I was lowkey on Shark Tank for a second the way you guys like rehearsed it
And we're saying it like together at the end because sometimes they do that on there
um everything to me was perfect i love the fragrance i definitely could see this being
something that i use um just because like i like the fragrance i like obviously i'm going to use
a body wash i always use something that's like ph balancing it's going to keep my color lasting a
lot longer um so with that being said i also do shower like two three times a day because i'm a
weirdo um would you ever consider doing like a bigger bottle size i think that there is definitely
the option for it and i think that there's even the option to expand further find a moisturizer
riser that can complement it right like i think there's a large um field that you could take this
into once you get the wheels turning so yeah absolutely i use a lot of body wash that's why
i want to be good all right good stuff thank you ladies excellent pitch okay you guys are being
very patient down there because i know it's a long time to stand i thank you so much for giving all
of your attention to our last presenters please oh we gotta do our judges i keep forgetting that
that part. I should be fired. All right. Michaela, you got a number for me? We got a 97. Holy.
Gina, a 97. A 91 from Jess. A 92 from Nick. A 91. A 95. 95. Well done, ladies. Okay,
Okay, our final presenters.
Chelsea and Alex, are you joining?
Yes.
All right.
So Chelsea and Alex are the proud owners of Hollywood Sunspot in Stony Creek
and Paradise Tan in Hamilton.
So I'm going to challenge you guys.
I'm going to challenge you guys in your awesome Canadian getup.
Let's pretend you're at the Canada Day Festival
and you're waiting in line for the loo
and you happen to get in line behind the CEO for one of these great big companies,
can you hit us with your pitch that's going to have them saying,
take my money?
Absolutely.
Okay, we'll try.
Go ahead.
Okay, have you ever thought about maybe simplifying the tanning routine for our clients
so they can tan smarter and glow longer?
We would like to introduce Duology.
It's the first of its kind dual chamber tanning solution
designed for the complete indoor tanning skincare routine. This innovative two-in-one system delivers
both an indoor tanning solution and a hydrating tan extender in one sleek, ergonomically designed
bottle. We truly believe that the options for this bottle are endless. We've started with just
an intensifier on stage one and a tan extender on stage two, but this really could go as far as
doing a tingle on side one and a facial on side two, an intensifier on side one and a bronzer on
side too the options are literally endless and we think this would be amazing to give to our clients
okay judges you're going through your materials still who's got the first question miss gina
okay i love the versatility i love the dual like this to me is just it screams amazingness but now
when you have bronzer on the left side is this going to be uh instant natural bronzer um a dual
dual bronzer or what, what, what, like we delayed VHA, what do we got? So with this one that we gave
you specifically, it's just an intense fire and a tan extender because we were going very simple
with it. But if we're talking about bronzer, you could do whatever. You could do an intense fire
on one side and a natural bronzer. You could do delayed and natural. We are always telling our
clients how important it is to have multiple products in their routine. This is a great way
to introduce that to them in a simplified way without throwing a thousand bottles at them.
So the only negative thing I would say is maybe do this brown just a little bit lighter
so when you do pop out with that, like, dual-use bronzer, you can richen it up.
But absolutely amazing.
Like, wow.
Definitely a cool innovation.
Love the name.
Name is fantastic.
It's just very, very original in name.
I would challenge you on the price.
I think you really undervaluated at $75 Canadian.
Canadian this is two six and a half ounce products really if you look at it I think I think you're
way lower than you should be with the name the story and I agree this is an entire line in the
making we got body wash and scrub you got face and body you've got no bronzer or bronzer I mean
there's so many different things you can do with this um talk to me a little bit about the bottle
itself is it heavy um how does it feel in my hand because it's of course it's got a channel cavity
cavity in the middle to separate. So just talk to me my ownership when I'm holding it because
when we're at the salon we always like to put the product in their hand because that's ownership
right? So tell me about that a little. I think I can answer that one. So I think the general width
of that bottle would be kind of like a tanning center bottle you know about four inches wide in
that regard with that sleek ergonomic design. That way it fits in the hand. Now obviously the
challenge of splitting that bottle down the middle that would be up to our wonderful manufacturers
is to figure out in that regard um but i think it's um it wouldn't be any wider than a hemp nation
bottle as an example to be honest with you with that durabilcations bottle like it you would be
able to kind of sleek it down so yeah i think that'd be the best bet first off i love this
concept because i feel like it simplifies you guys said that word i love that great buzzword
and i feel like um like you said the combinations are endless you know you could i could even see
like a body wash with a shave or shaving moisturizer as well you could do a facial
lotion with like a primer so again possibilities are endless so in terms of like the creativity
for this bottle very very cool um and again simplifies it for your customer your consumer
a couple questions though first and foremost um you i noticed the fragrance is the fragrance the
same in both products that do you vision it being in the same like fragrance or and talk a little
bit about that fragrance i mean in this particular one we're going with that coconut vanilla musk
as sort of the buzzword for that fragrance.
You're going for a very unisex gendered fragrance, right?
Because with the musk scent coupled with the vanilla,
it's a very, like, luscious vibe
with a little bit of a coconut water blended in there.
Like, it could just be very neutral across the board.
Cool.
Whether or not it's the same scent.
Yep.
And is the base the same?
Sorry, I'll let you respond, Chelsea,
to that question on the fragrance too.
And then another thing is, is the base the same?
like what are the key hero kind of call-outs in that base because obviously it sounds like it's
like in a collection you're envisioning that we went like first on the fragrance when we were
thinking about unisex fragrance one of the clients that came to mind i was thinking about typically
our male clients who i don't use lotion i don't use product i don't like to put this on my skin
why are you handing me five bottles i now need to put on so with that one it was simplifying it so
i thought having a unisex fragrance was better for them um in this one i would do both the same
fragrance I find if you talk to some people they love having their lotion in
their body spray be the same fragrance I thought that was key in terms of the
base ingredients with this one again we tried to keep it really simple so we
went with just two things that we love to see in products which was tyrosine
and hemp seed oil they're two of our hero ingredients that we love to talk
about they've been around forever and there's a reason but I think you could
we talked about price point you could go so far with this where you have like
like an incredible skincare product in here
with niacinamide and bakuchi oil,
and you could go crazy,
and those could be your hero ingredients in those ones.
That's great.
Love that response.
Good job.
Hey, guys.
I love the Target market.
I think specifically for guys having one bottle
that they can carry and kind of both products within there.
I will challenge you on the pumps, though,
and I think there was a VersaSpa product
that had two products in one tube
with a flip cap on the bottom.
yeah and that was like i don't know pretty old school maybe not as old school as ganja as earlier
but uh i think that you know that kind of product design might fit the product a little bit better
just only because it's just a little easier to use and you don't have to try to close the pump
after you tan but love the concept love the fragrance love the target demographic you guys
nailed this i was literally gonna say the same thing as nick kind of in the same way that i
wrote that down i think everything was great i also personally am like i work for a lotion
manufacturer and i'm a lazy lotion user okay i like quick i like easy especially like you know
just i run downstairs and tan run back upstairs so i like that idea um i was just gonna say the
pumps i know not necessarily guys come in with like a purse a lot of ladies come in with like
a tanning bag and i just worry about like the pump kind of like getting all over the bag or
something but it's not absolutely everybody's like problem but just something that you could
consider with like a different type of pump but i really like the idea of two because people like
like easy and i always when i do sales trainings always like make things easier people because
that's how you sell let's make things easy that's why it says step one tan step two extend
great job y'all thank you amazing
i'm on our jeopardy music lloyd even if it's just for a second
looks like we've got some scores the stairs have you all had a chance now to scan the qr code this
is your opportunity to do that we can have we can pass some of these qr codes out if that's helpful
okay amazing oh okay you guys are way ahead of me good stuff all right our judges have their scores
and then we've got a 90 that'll get the crowd talking just with an amazing 98 with an
an exclamation mark 98 from gina and 87 from nick and an 86 from michaela it's almost like these
judges are talking at their tables all right one more time a huge huge round of applause for all
of our presenters guys that takes a lot of guts to get up here and do that i you know i i've been
doing this for a long time elaine's been doing this for a lot all of these judges you know
sometimes we all take it for granted what it takes to get up and talk in front of people and
And not everyone has that skill.
So they're already winners today.
Just the simple fact that they went through the process,
they came up with an idea, and they shared it with you all.
So I'm actually going to invite Alex and Chelsea back up for a moment, please,
if you guys can take your spot back.
We had some, I'll just call them like secret shopper judges in the crowd today,
because if you recall, we did ask you, and you guys, seriously,
brought it for this theme today the canada theme look at the red the denim you guys all look
absolutely one thousand percent amazing huge round of applause for yourself stepping up email that
means you read the email hooray uh alex and chelsea you guys are our winners for best dress today
little gift for you we've got a prize for you for that all right so you guys brought your
Your creativity, your strategy, and a whole lot of passion to the table.
And we really, really appreciate you doing that.
To our judges, thank you so much for lending your thought and your ideas
and sharing your experience with our participants today.
High fives, high fives.
All right.
Crystal, how are we doing on the draw tickets?
Okay.
So do you guys have your draw tickets ready?
Yes?
All right.
so while we tabulate our final pitch scores we're going to do our draws okay okay are you going to
be down there to get okay so the way this is going to work crystal tells me is i'm going to read out
the ticket number and we need a record of you if you have one so if you wouldn't mind maybe popping
popping upstairs to actually Lise. Hello. Do you want Lise to write down? Okay, all we need is your
salon name apparently. If you just holler at me your salon name as these Americans would say,
just holler at me. I can write it down too please Lise, we'll have a double copy. So we're starting
with our Australian Gold 2025 intro kit. I have a yellow ticket, yellow and white coupon. The number
I have is five seven nine one two eight three seven once again yellow and white
coupon five seven we got a winner two beaches we got a winner okay next our
Swedish beauty vital intro kit I have a blue and white coupon blue and white
Blue and white. All right. Red numbering on the side. 0720841. All right. And what salon?
Midnight Sun. Congratulations. Designer Skin 2025 Intro Kit. I have a red and white coupon
with black numbering on the bottom red and white coupon the number I have is five eight zero two
three five six two I'll read it again red and white coupon five eight zero two three five six
two we got one what salon dark desire congratulations California tan 2025 intro
kit. I have a blue and white admit one coupon with blue line written on the bottom. Black numbers on
the side. Blue and white coupon. Admit one. The number is 6059231. And what salon are you from?
Purity. Congratulations. Next up we've got a devoted creations 2025 color rush kit. I've got
got a blue and black coupon admit one a blue and black coupon the number on the bottom is four four
one nine five zero one we got one what's the line sorry i didn't hear it oh sprays by rays
congratulations next one is we've got a hemp's botanical sunshine gift bag i've got a yellow
and white ticket yellow and white ticket this is a hemp's botanical sunshine gift
bag from our friends at sunny five seven nine one two eight three one all right
apparently standing somewhere down here has an advantage guys salon what's the
one? Eye tan? Oh, eye candy? All right, eye candy. Congratulations. Apparently I need glasses for my
ears too, guys. I've got a Hemp's Hydro Whip Maximizer Bag Deal up for grabs next. This is a
white and blue coupon that says blue line on the bottom. Five zero, sorry, never mind, starting
again six zero five nine one nine three six yeah awesome congratulations what
salon tan licious congratulations next we have a pro tan endgame bag deal I've
got another yellow and white coupon yellow and white with the black letters
on the bottom or sorry black numbers on the bottom five seven nine one two seven five nine
five seven nine one two seven five nine yellow and white somebody have one oh up here okay
chelsea congratulations you can hand that to lee's downstairs next prize up for grabs is the
supreme 2025 boss lady intro kit i've got a blue and white ticket the numbers on the side are nine
one nine four two nine zero nine one nine four two nine zero going nine one nine four two nine
990. Yay! What salon are you from? Sorry, Lane. Okay, next up we have a Devoted Creations kit.
I've got a red and white ticket this time. Red and white ticket, 580-23-441. 580-23-441.
Got one? Awesome. What's your salon name? Elite Tan? All right. Congratulations.
The next. Oh, this is a good one. We got a $250 gas card up for grabs.
We have a yellow and white ticket. The yellow and white ticket for this gas card.
5-7-9-1-2-5-4-2. 5-7-9-1-2-5-4-2. Yay!
What's your salon?
Fabitan.
Which one?
London.
Do you know your number?
113?
Congratulations.
Next, we have a $250 gift card for Aritzia.
A red and white ticket, guys.
Red and white ticket.
58023625.
This is a red and white ticket.
it? 5-8-0-2-3-6-2-5. Anyone going once? Going. Right? The judges want it. They're the donators,
but they want this. Thank you so much to all of our vendors who donated these prizes. This is
amazing. I will. It's a red and white ticket. It's 5802-3625. You got it? Nice. What salon are you
from? Sol Exotica. Which one? Ancaster? Next, we're giving away a Norvell Glow System. I've got a blue
and white ticket for this guy blue and white ticket looks like we've got three
Norval glow systems to give away so this is our first one six zero five nine zero
seven two six zero five nine zero seven two blue and white ticket anyone blue
Blue and white ticket, 6-0-5, 9-0-7-2.
Going once, going twice.
All right, we're going to pause that one and carry on with the next.
This is also for a Norval Glow system.
I've got a red and white ticket this time.
Red and white ticket, 5-0.
Never mind.
Numbers are starting to blend together, guys, even though I'm wearing my glasses.
Okay, red and white ticket, 580-23649.
580-23649, red and white ticket.
Boy, these Norvell glow systems are hard to give away.
I'll take it.
Red and white ticket, 580-23649.
Alright, hold please. Third glow system. Oh, we got one. So that was 649. Sol Exotica, which one? Ancaster? Alright. Yellow and White Ticket. Yellow and White Ticket. This is another Norval glow system.
system five seven nine one two six nine five five seven nine one two six nine five looking
for two six nine five on a yellow ticket you got it Rosie okay Rosie from Suntastic congratulations
this is okay so we're back on the Norval glow system we we didn't have a winner on the first
ticket so we've got drawn another one so this is norval glow uh sorry blue and black ticket
the blue and black ticket is four four one nine five two four four four one nine five two four
oh we got one all right what salon are you from babby tan one five two did somebody just pass that
that ticket over for her to Emily for me, please.
Thank you so much.
Congratulations.
All right, now these super cute little beavers
up here from Flo Day,
we've got one to give away as well for you guys.
A blue and white ticket.